for the sake of
entertaining the listeners let's talk
about when you were
like salty like right like why did you
like do
am i corrected you like just gotten a
feud
a rat beef with eminem yeah yeah we got
we
it's all love now of course you know
what i mean but yeah we got into it and
it was more of a um it was an ugly
ugly battle you know but that's because
we're both from detroit and our camps
were fighting it it wasn't
us in eminem scrapping somewhere you
know what i mean it was our camps
fighting each other and that was that
wasn't good and that was bad you know
what i mean
it was like you know what i mean those
guys would be at somewhere and we would
be somewhere and it would just be a
[ __ ]
war jumping off on the street you know
and it wouldn't even involve
him or us at all you know what i mean
and that was just [ __ ] up man for a
long time you know what i mean that was
an ugly fight man
and before he passed away uh proof
um who was eminem's right-hand man and
and of course
he's a lot more than that especially
here in detroit man he's like
um he's like a godfather rap here in
detroit he's like a um
legend you know what i mean um but proof
um was on a mission it seemed
to squash a lot of the beefs eminem had
you know what i mean yeah in this like
about the
right about the year he died proof was
doing this and and
he reached out to us and we had like a
bowling match
it was us versus d12 and like a bowling
match you know
that was [ __ ] awesome i was so proud
that he included us
because like i said we were the most
hated band it was like
i'll [ __ ] them they don't count you know
like if you if you were naming off
groups
music um that was successful from
detroit
you could name off all kind of people
and then somebody'd say what about icp
oh man
[ __ ] them they don't count you know what
i mean it was always like that
so when proof included us to squash the
beef
and he he came to our office and um
and like he jumped on a song with one of
our groups
and um he gave us a shout out in his
verse and [ __ ] it was just
it meant a lot to us man i mean it
really meant a lot you know what i mean
and um he ended up being killed
just months later and i wanted to go to
the funeral you know but but um
i didn't know if eminem himself
knew about what proof was doing to the
extent
right and i didn't want to show up at
bruce funeral and that ma'am and them
see us they're like what the [ __ ] are
they doing here you know what i mean
and i i didn't want to take the chance
of something like that happening
you know what i mean um because i know
he was so much closer to proof
i mean so much incredibly closer you
know it just
it was it was a [ __ ] up time you know
what i mean um
but uh yeah you know that was an ugly
war for a long time man
damn yeah you know yeah
dude